yeah I went to welcome to this video
playing I am meat-eor 84 9 f 3 okay huh
it's not very frequently seen
interesting probably 92 now and it tries
to attack my pawn really put if up on
could prove to be a weakness now it
seems quite logical how do I support
that pawn I wonder if d 5 is actually
moves like tapes then 93 Queen to h5
[Music]
display at least I'm covering this
reliably Knight f6 Bishop f5 is always
possible it looks a bit strange up with
the Queen but let me put in five is not
a bad spot for the Queen if if it is
reasonably safe now and cannot be
attacked all that often yeah I know it
looks lucky but h5 comes into
consideration or not do that H voice
strong if it happens oh he's not worried
here
yeah maybe because of because of not
sure because of what I am Bishop f5 here
3 defiance Nolan doesn't work we should
I five is looking good aha so we should
see to this Bishop takes his six so I
take it he takes to the night band and
we should be six me that's not bad I
just want to ever have something better
Bishop t6 maybe the night is still
attacked sorry
yoga that's quite active position yeah
where to put it I think here i am to
make to cover d5 better okay so i won't
ever should actually play this age phone
I think I i do that it's not bad okay so
probably taking make sense the bishop is
covering xfc seven so you can take your
first and now castling long is looking
nice who I can take 25 Wow ok and just
bishop the ship shakes I guess on yeah
nothing wrong with that yeah I can take
and take even on be too I'm not sure
that I want to take I mean I can also
just do this now look is quite active
yeah might be run on third what no this
is the winning position for black so 94
93 f both might be three SS good Jericho
certain completely out kills off the
roof only three so just bring the King
up to the g6
King c6 and if I trade one look then I'm
just going to yahoo KJ that was a bit
stronger the term this is also cave so
let's see should have really trade it
one look at would have been better
time warning
94 94 I guess and then March the bball
okay man quite a bit because pawns are
pretty good i am ok ok bit unnatural
this move it should work
okay okay quite recently okay so I catch
all for was kind of weird yeah so let's
let's have a look there I think that's
an interesting opening actually for
white I mean I've never really looked at
this but it isn't it's quite interesting
I mean if I don't play 85 I don't see
how I support the center all that well I
like if I do this and he goes here i am
not quite sure like g3 Bishop g2 that
pawn could become weak i have no natural
way to cover it so i know i think that
that looked quite sensible this Queen to
e5 thing and the SG 3 engine wants to go
deform feels very natural and okay this
is not liked by the computer oh well
okay so it's clear that I don't need to
play this I can play the show see file
or something but i feel that wasn't so
bad and wonder why this likes it so much
the capture and then create 60 k can
switch that on also hello yeah m and
then create six liked a lot by the
engine yeah okay i understand they
understand and also Bishop f4 is coming
okay no I didn't see that correct them
that I didn't evaluate correctly I mean
yeah I think I should be fine very
active pieces
a 94 with even stronger I would I mean
I'm finding anyway so this was a bit
shocking either and now I'm just glue I
just just winning him taking me too long
but it doesn't really as a matter of
technical play now yeah thank you loud
something with a one clicker proly those
also were pretty nice now not much to do
that and interesting open they have
never seen this once or twice 90th read
a bit I'm kind of kind of unique
dispositions id-5 i think is correct the
engine line is pretty funky Knight f6
understand drinking 9f 693 85 that is
some compensation that's fine but really
add something amazing that's amazing
that this should be compensation I mean
okay I understand that black has the bio
development but what is to send two
pawns and currently no weakness okay
yeah thanks for watching